[Music]
hello and welcome to film independent
presents my name is rachel bloomer
director of events for film and defended
uh before we get started with today's
very exciting q a i have to give some
praise to our loyal supporters thank you
to our incredible lead sponsor the
hollywood forum press association and
our screening partner vision media
and with that i'm honored to introduce
our guest moderator for today please
welcome carlos aguilar i will take it
from here thank you everyone for uh for
being here and you know welcome everyone
who just watched the movie i'm very
excited to be here with you know an
incredible group of people uh with
director clint bentley producer greg
wetter uh molly parker and clifton
collins greg i hope i pronounced your
last name correctly i apologize over
there
you were really close
the k threw me off um
so clint why don't we start with you i
mean your father was a jockey and you
know i feel like you know coming from
such a personal place i wonder what the
process was from
you know taking those the personal
insight that you have into this world
that most of us don't have
and then shaping that into you know a
screenplay and sort of like you know
giving giving form to jockey
out of all the things you do in life
there's that one minute
that you feel like you're the most
important thing in the world because
everybody's watching you
i was a great jockey
for a little while
[Music]
how you doing jax i'm doing real good
i'm feeling good just tell me what's
going on
it's it's just wear and tear
coming across the stress that's right
let them feel it i'm gonna push back i'm
gonna pull it back push back look i know
i'm not the same shape as these young
cats but i still got a good couple years
left in me
[Music]
yeah it it started from that place of of
having a very specific feeling that i
just wanted to share
uh through a movie and and that was just
the feeling of of what it feels like to
be on the backside of the racetrack
um
and and how i felt like
i felt like there had been a lot of
movies about racing but none had really
uh had really gotten that lifestyle
across um and then also showing the life
of of a jockey which which i didn't feel
like had been explored and then through
the process of that
first with greg and i writing the
scripts and and seeing the world through
his eyes who had never really seen it
before and and seeing all the things
that he discovered
and then clifton and molly both bring so
much of their lives into the into the
process and and their discoveries from
working with jockeys and trainers and
the research that they did it really
just like started from that little germ
and it became this um
thing much bigger than i i ever thought
it could be
and greg you know you from for you to
coming into this world that perhaps was
you know foreign for you uh you know
what did you feel that you were able to
to perhaps bring or check or you know
give some perspective that maybe clint
you know being so close to it couldn't
have
that's a great question you know the
first thing we did was
go to a track down in houston and we
were on the back side and we slept in a
tack room with all the racing equipment
and
as the sun rose um you know the prayers
were going on on the loudspeakers in
english and spanish and already it just
sort of felt
sort of the texture like richness of the
place which is really how we start we
you know we build our stories from the
dirt up and then we came out to the
rails as the morning exercises were
starting
exactly as the movie starts
and it was in that place you know as as
the horses were going every which
direction and you know the outriders
were talking crap you know on the rails
and it just
immediately felt um
that that was where the life was that
you know the life was in the community
on the backside and that felt so
immediately alive
uh and worth following
but really it was just kind of
you know clint has this sort of deep
immense uh
you know wealth of of understanding of
of these people um through his own life
and it was really just like kind of
following curiosity just asking
questions like what makes a great jockey
and seeing 10 different people answer it
10 different ways or what makes a horse
special and great getting 10 different
answers from 10 different people and
within that you start to just find your
way
with the story which is really the last
thing that comes for us
so clifton you had worked with bill
clinton and greg before in trans pecos
and i wonder you know of course you had
you built the relationship with them in
that first effort but you still had to
you know be convinced and lured into a
new project you know with a great
character so i wonder you know
what was that sort of first conversation
about jockey after you guys had worked
on transpecos
you know um when you do an independent
film you you get to forge these bonds
that you might not do on a on a big
commercial film
so uh that that collaborative experience
on the first one
um
[Music]
it really
it just makes it really open for one to
collaborate and be creative so there
wasn't a whole lot of convincing make
sure we had they had to get a story
together but um first and foremost they
developed an immense a trust
with me and uh and uh
a sense of loyalty so
um you know
it was clint's turn let's jump
in a ride or die let's do it
and molly you had him work with them
right so you had to be convinced a
little more perhaps too
to join this cast
yeah it wasn't it wasn't particularly
difficult though i have to say they were
you know by the time they approached me
they had
a script that was really very very good
and
and they had shot some
they had shot some stuff at a track and
it was so what they sent was just so
colorful and cinematic and clearly
you know they had
a gr they had they
they hadn't they had an eye i mean they
what they were showing me was something
that i i haven't seen before and um
so there were those things i also um you
know clifton is just one of my favorite
actors we did it we did a panel
for
ifp like 20 years ago together i think
it's the first time we met and i
you know i felt
that this was like a role that i wanted
to see him do so i wanted to come and
support that and um
and they also
really early on in our first
conversation they sent me a bunch of
images there was one i remember of a
woman like hugging a cougar in this very
uh
i don't know there was just something
different about the way they were
thinking you know
so i was intrigued
seems like a very interesting image
can you elaborate on that
we greg and i for every film make a
lookbook of the film um and it's just
like
trying to get it one step uh between the
the white the black and white of the
page of the script into like you know
visual storytelling and visual thinking
um and so the lookbook there you know
there are always a lot of photos of of
the world that we're going to step into
and then there's some random stuff that
are just feeling images
and for the character pages we do a page
on every every one of the main
characters
and
you know
the images that we select for those are
not like oh here's a couple of actresses
who this could be which is usually what
it is you know usually because lots of
people do look books and they send you
you know a page of other actresses
[Laughter]
you know we wrote that role hoping that
that molly would take it but but we
didn't know how much we would have to
beg molly and and if we and if we
wouldn't be successful um
but you know the the images that we
select for the characters are more like
random weird images that give you the
sense of the character rather than uh
rather than a picture of an actor you
could tell they were artists that's
awesome
yeah and a woman hugging a cougar just
um clifton what was the process like for
you to get into this you know this
character you know to become a jock in
sort of the physicality of a part like
this
the physicality uh you know honestly
first and foremost it's just being um
having the opportunity to be embraced
and to
delve into the world of the jockeys
um
once uh once i i was starting to feel
like uh one of the new guys amongst the
jockeys it was easier to uh acclimate
and live as they did which uh was
an extreme diet
to say the least um it's not a keto diet
and i was usually done eating by one or
three in the morning i dropped to 143
so it's whatever
they did i wanted to do you just want to
belong i'm sure we're making a movie but
first and foremost
once i was able to uh
get lost within the world to make that
world mine as much as possible and and
feel as though i belonged to
a community of jockeys uh i just built
from there
and we were shooting on a live track so
it was all happening and so we were
around those people all the time
greg was it always you know you know
from your side as a producer was it
difficult to sort of engage with a live
track and non-actors and sort of the
account the complications or you know
benefits of doing it that way sort of
like in the real world
i mean there yes
there are certainly challenges but we
really never
envisioned it in that way i mean it was
all it was sort of part of the ethos of
the of the original um impetus to do the
movie was could we step into this live
existing track could we join this
community on the back side and if we
would have had
this kind of massive sort of studio
footprint on it we would have missed
you know everything that was right in
front of our eyes and so
there were so many things that we were
kind of pushing the boundaries on in
terms of like the model in which we
financed the film but also the crew size
where we we made it with a crew of 10.
um and the intentionality of that was so
that because there were so many
first-time
actors joining us uh
we didn't want this sort of huge
apparatus to
get it get between them and their
vulnerability um to sort of bare
themselves to us that we we wanted to
you know the film to almost fold into
this real place um and and join them
and so we were really conscious of
you know how big we were um as we
stepped into that world
clinton you know for you as a director
can you talk about the process of sort
of merging the you know your your cast
of professional actors and sort of the
world that you were entering
yeah it was it was something i was
worried about from the beginning because
you can always in a lot of movies you
can see it
pretty much immediately when it's like
oh here's a scene with two professional
actors and then now you know they're
going to talk to people who've never
acted before and it just feels very off
um as a viewer
and
uh and so there was a lot of time and a
lot of thought put into how best to do
that so it doesn't feel like you've got
two different movies going on at the
same time
um and a big part of it was
what you were just saying a second ago
um props to our producer nancy schaefer
as well for like she just created such a
community out there uh with with the
people that she got to know that they
all felt like they wanted to make the
movie with us
um but then also just these actors um
clifton and and molly and and moises
arias as well were just
so
incredible at being able to to slip into
a scene with a first-time actor
and someone who had never been on camera
before
and a lot of times they're
they were doing scenes that
um you know they weren't just like ad
living things they were needing to hit
certain things and
um and
uh these actors just made them feel so
comfortable in front of the camera and
helped guide them through the scene and
it it made my job much easier i have to
say
molly i i what i love about your
character is that you know it's a strong
character and it's not a romantic
interest you know it's a different type
of relationship that we're used to
seeing you know in in certain films so i
i wonder if that was part of you know
your attraction to to this character
that was you know a strong presence in
this story
yeah i was i
[Music]
i really like her and um
one of the first things that we talked
about uh the guys and i they they turned
me on to this documentary about this
uh
trainer not a racehorse trainer but a
horse trainer down in like patagonia
and
just her way of being with these animals
and being with these horses and i so i i
kind of conceived of
ruth as sort of like the lead mayor you
know like in a in a
pack of horses the female
mayor is sort of the alpha of of the
group but the
way of leading is this completely
different uh it's not alpha in the way
that we think about it in the animal
world it's just like this really strong
presence and
that's kind of what i wanted to try to
put together and to try to reflect
something
as we went along of um
of the themes that clifton was going
through you know and just to show this
friendship of people who have loved each
other for a long time
and have you know their their they work
together there's a boss employer
relationship there's a friendship
there's history and um
and if there's romance it's like comes
and goes or it's whatever you know it's
not it's not the important part of of
the
of the relationship and clifton and i
just
made it up it was really fun we had such
a good time
we clicked pretty hard it was um and
also i
you know when clint calls action molly
molly turns it on and it's it's hard to
he just turns it on it's just like wow
you're like
very easily could have been a romance
the source between jackson
and you know molly or jackson
[Laughter]
clifton to to sort of understand
jackson's you know what he's going
through in terms of you know his body
sort of not being what he used to be and
sort of coming to terms with you know
with the end of of of this part of his
life in terms of being a jockey i wonder
you know psychologically do you
you know do you try to understand the
character that way or is it more
intuitive your process
it's a combination of two things uh
also when you get to hang out with the
jockeys and see what they go through
it's it's very easy to uh kind of
i don't know
live with those uh injuries they're
almost like a
phantom injury when you when you get an
amputation or something you still feel
the pain so i think as an actor when you
when you delve into those roles and
um thankfully i had clint constantly
reminding me of like you know your
condition is getting a little worse now
after a little that or or i'd go off and
research um certain ailments that
jockeys go through you know you uh you
tell yourself these things and enough
times
you start to think that you're feeling
it and that's that's the place you want
to be
uh i mean i think i still feel some of
those things i maybe that's just me
and not jackson but uh yeah so i i get
into it that way
and um
those feelings kind of stay with you for
a while you gotta they're kind of hard
to shake unless you jump into like
a role right away
if i had like the role of a
contortionist or something they'd
probably disappear
[Laughter]
well if i make clifton's such an
intuitive actor and and
really
makes
made me a better director made greg and
i better writers in terms of just like
he's constantly asking questions and and
it's
they sometimes you don't even know why
he's asking them until you get to a
scene five days later and you're like oh
[ __ ] that's why he was that's why he was
asking about this um
but it was something that was just
you know when he was
any any scene that he was interacting in
whether it was him walking by himself on
a on a track for for a minute at sunset
for us to get a shot or
or interacting with with a first-time
actor
um it really
was amazing once we got in the edit
there wasn't a lot of having to trim
around like okay that feels off because
that that line doesn't feel like the
character all just felt like one
continuous
person that he had built it was amazing
another testament to cliff is you know
it started on trans pecos
where you know every night he would
invite
all the leads and and clint and i to his
room and you walk into this hotel room
and every corner of every wall on the
floor are covered in notes and post-its
and
you know poetry and you know
ideas for monologues and you know in
every margin of every script page is
covered in stains and you know like
it'll you know some of these will be in
the academy museum at some point but
but on
on jockey um we sort of took it to
another level we did that same thing and
and it's a testament to to molly and
moises too to be so game
to come in and like open up what we were
gonna do the next day and bring all of
these personal experiences they were all
having molly with the trainer she was
following moises and clifton with the
jockeys they were with what clint and i
were seeing on the back side
and it just became the sort of fur the
script then became the sort of fertile
living organism that kept sort of
revealing itself to us
absolutely it's also a beautiful movie
you know in terms of the visual elements
of it but a lot of that has to do with
shooting during magic hour you
know this beautiful moment so greg tells
you know how complicated and perhaps you
know difficult was to capture the film
almost you know entirely in this in
these moments
where we get to shoot like four hours a
day you mean um no honestly um i bought
into it really
quickly you know adolfo veloso our dp um
is um
is a magician
um he's he's an empath but he's also
like highly
highly focused and and um
and and the things he can do with the
camera you know baffle me
but what
what he really latched on to was one
just a subjective experience of jackson
and that's something that clinton had
found together but also one thing he
brought to us was like you know the
rhythms of a jockey are they exercise
before dawn and they race in the
evenings and then the horses and the
jockeys are resting in the day
and so our production kind of started to
mer you know because that was what we
could film at a live working racetrack
also it matched this sort of character
in the twilight of his career
and then on top of that you know we
could then conform our production to
this
we would sort of rest when they would
rest or we would shoot interiors you
know but we you know we were able to
sort of
fit into
their their flow
yeah i definitely love since the first
time i watched the film the idea of you
know the
the lighting choices reflecting this
twilight and the dusk of
you know the younger guy that's sort of
coming up and i feel like that's really
dramatically matches beautifully with
the aesthetics of the film
um you know let's talk about the
father-son relationship that's formed
between jackson and moyes's character uh
and i wonder clint if you could talk
about writing and then we could hear
from clifton about you know developing
that with moises
yeah it it came from
a few different things one the obvious
of
my father being a jockey and uh and some
of the first scripts didn't really deal
with that um and they were a little the
first versions didn't really deal with
that that sort of theme
and then i had a friend uh tell me that
the scripts the those drafts were a
little flat because he's like you're not
really letting yourself open up to that
uh thing that you have to deal with
um
and and then it just kind of really
developed as we went along one
interesting aspect was
every time we talked to jockeys
they all
you know they all
their lives were so
they got meaning from from what they did
and it's it's not just a job for for
most of them it's it's something that's
really like brings
uh it's some deep aspect in their life
um
at the same time when we would ask them
do you want your kid to be a jockey
it's the last thing they wanted their
daughter son to be was was to grow up
and be a jockey um even though it meant
so much to them because they knew what
it would what that would entail
and then just you know the as as greg
was saying a minute ago just all of our
lives coming into this script um
a lot of that uh
father-son
uh theme just kept growing of
clifton's
life and and and his own connection with
his father and and what he had been
through
at the tracks which is
kind of verbatim that last
uh
monologue he gives to moises's character
gabriel in the in the end is is from
clifton's own life and he can talk about
that
um and greg had adopted a son along the
way while we were making the film and so
it all just kind of like kept growing
um but i let clifton talk specifically
about
about
that and moises and
because you guys would work together
right clifton like we did moses and i we
worked together on a film called the
perfect game about 12 years ago probably
longer
and um
there were about i think five five five
little boys on there that i i ended up
mentoring and uh and continued a
relationship with them until i mean
until now like they got their own
families now deep voices and stuff it's
funny
but uh moyes is uh
he stood out to me because uh he was the
littlest guy
with the with the biggest like just
you know because he the littlest and the
oldest and so he had to speak big he had
to act big and um
i i think i saw a lot of myself in him
and i remember uh showing some friends
some pictures of him and i together
playing around on set because i took a
lot of behind the scene photos
and video um
and some friends of mine were like oh my
god that looks like your son that could
be your son i was like
yeah and i started looking like yeah i
guess so
and here we go years later greg and
clint my manager were like how about
moises
and it was just a perfect fit
also you know there's been some time
um so he's had time to mature time to
become an adult
this cultured young individual is
insanely talented
um so
we're meeting
it's a different meeting of mines um
still beautiful nonetheless and
i'm very grateful to have
rekindled it on this level
so it's really special um and i think
all artists have uh issues with their
parents i think that's one of the
reasons why they are
and also for me it's a bloodline as well
what was this monologue that that clint
was referencing
it's the monologue at the end when um
uh
my uh
gabe gabe slash moises shows me this
photo and it's a photo i
lost long ago
i've probably lost all my photos just
from moving all the time and living that
lifestyle
and um it triggers all these memories
and stuff so for me personally
as a child you know my my parents
divorced when i was young
and uh
my dad was supposed to see me every
other weekend um me and my sister but
you know sometimes he'd make it
sometimes he wouldn't sometimes he'd be
hung over or he'd show up drunk and my
grandmother sent him on his way because
he was intoxicated but if he was sober
enough to pick us up
a lot of times my weekends would be
picking the horses
that would win play a show
i learned how to read
the programs early on i was like you
know eight nine years old
doing a math word problems at a young
age that was a good side that was good
it helped
but uh in regards to fun it's like uh
you just wanna spend time with your dad
it doesn't matter if he's getting wasted
with his buddies you're still a fly on
the wall
you know so but i i was the one picking
the horses
um you know clint and clifton you know i
something that i said you know from the
beginning when i first saw the movie was
that i love that you know this is a
movie about two latino man you know
father and son that's not about their
identity and that you know just lets the
characters exist in the world but also
doesn't deny you know i think the first
words that clinton that kind of cliff's
character says in the movie in spanish
and it sort of feels like the right
balance between you know
not sort of like hiding it but also not
making about that and i wonder how that
came to be
i mean
very organically just just from from
from our side of things writing the
script uh you know we were writing it
for for clifton
and
it just
whether it's
whether you're writing a role for for um
a character who who is hispanic in in
this care in this uh situation or or a
woman in the in the case of ruth
it for all of us
those things help define us but they
don't completely define us and we're
we're people outside of those things and
so
and so it was very organic and natural
um but i think it's also just what
people want to see because it's what we
experience in our day-to-day lives
um of
yeah that the thing that jackson is
going to throw out as oneness and
instead of high or hello um
but then he doesn't have to
it's he's not going to be
um using every monologue to talk about
uh how this has changed his life or
whatever i don't know clifton
maybe well i'll just add one thing of
just
you know i think the deeper
deeper human understanding kind of
occurs through proximity to others you
know
and
i think so much of what
the reason jackson became jackson was
because of a deep
friendship with clifton
and getting to know
these qualities within them the cements
warmth the sadness that's there
you know all of this depth and range
that
you know that you wouldn't have seen
just through a filmography that that can
only come from
uh bearing ourselves to each other and
in that friendship and that's sort of
the process of which the script grew
from and that role grew out of
clifton anything you want to add
i mean no they're so eloquent
you have a specific question i speak to
yeah i mean did it did it matter to you
that this was you know a story that you
know
doesn't deny sort of your background you
know and
moses is also you know a young latino
actor but it also doesn't make it about
about the identity
that that was actually uh clinton craig
um
their geniusness because originally the
last time i had visited any tracks there
was a lot of cajun people i played cajun
before and i'm a character i love to do
different roles and it was clint that
called me one day and said
you know what do you think about going
latino and i was like what does that
mean exactly i'm like well it's a big
and i wasn't aware there's a big influx
of latino racers and this and that and i
was like oh wow started doing some
research and then when we got there it
seemed like the organic real thing to do
i mean even in that uh in many of the
scenes you'll see some that are probably
more obviously latino to some um and
others you wouldn't probably have a clue
that they're latino but i would because
i knew um
maybe just being in the jockeys room and
hanging out with them if i wanted to
just play games you know
just start speaking spanish to them
because i knew some of the white guys
didn't understand what we were saying
so that was fun especially
under the guise of they look pretty
white too so now it's like whoa these
white people don't speak spanish
[Laughter]
a lot of weddings a lot of those
um before we wrap clint i have to ask
you about casting the horses the other
actors in this film i mean i'm sure that
that was you know its own complication
to sort of like you know
decide which ones to shoot and how to
shoot them
yeah the the horses i mean they are they
are
they have personalities just like
everybody else um and and they're the
ones that are amazing racehorses that
that you don't really want to um bother
because they're they're pretty ornery
molly had quite a few experiences of
them just reaching out and trying to
bite her on the way past the storm
um
and we all did uh but not
me he's so proud no horse ever hit him
uh but no it was it was it was very it
was very conscious of of trying to find
a horse um luckily that
luckily the horses we were we're folding
ourselves into a live track where the
horses were doing what they do all the
time and so we were just kind of filming
them do what they do
um
and like the horse who plays dido's
laments uh that i think is above the law
um in real life
um
you know we had this scene where we greg
and i had seen in our research this this
you know area it's a sand area that like
um a little
uh
pen filled with soft sand where the
horses just go in and they they kind of
roll around and
and um they you know get their backs
loose and everything and uh and we were
told like this you know the horse will
do this but we didn't know what that
meant and
so then we all got there and stood
around and
they just put the horse in there and she
was put on this incredible show for us
uh that that's in the movie when when uh
ruth first introduces jackson to dido's
lament and it was just one of those
amazing things where it's like holy [ __ ]
this is better than anything we could
have storyboarded
molly was it was it fun for you to work
with the courses or was it a challenge i
i loved it i really loved it but it's
definitely um
you know these are
these are high strung animals that are
bred to race and they are
you know they're just a different thing
than a horse you would ride on a farm or
or a rodeo horse so
and they do all have different
personalities and some of them are
writers but um
but i loved just that and there's
something so tender about the energy of
like that thing of an animal that's been
broken and you know that brokenness
in terms of a theme that was running
through the film of of um
not just how you know clifton's
character is breaking down but but a lot
of these you know a lot of us who end up
in the arts or i think there's something
familiar about the kind of carny feel of
the back side of the track
that is
people carrying some trauma you know and
so i i there there's just something
really tender about and healing about
being around these
these animals
i think that's a beautiful note for us
to end this conversation thank you so
much clayne clifton molly and greg thank
you for joining us carlos thanks thank
you
carlos thank you guys
[Music]
you